let's go why don't we go to our caller
from the 732 area code and 732 is very
very dicey it's on the list along with 4
1 3 & 2 1 0 of often problematic area
codes but let's try it who's calling
today from the 732 hi David
my name is Joseph I am actually born in
the monmouth county area which is is is
kind of conservative along with Ocean
County is also a pretty conservative I
happen to live in New York City now but
and I wasn't Servat 'iv for her a little
bit of time really and then switched
yeah Wow yeah why did you switch
I switched I think because my my empathy
just kind of got to me my my empathy for
other people as opposed to being more
about like my own stuff and my own on my
own person hood but I have a lot of
friends who are conservatives and ends
both voted for Trump and we have
interesting conversations but and what
triggered that but anyway like in other
words so for a while you you say you
were kind of more self-centered and you
were conservative and then something
triggered your empathy for other people
and then you became you you moved to the
left what triggered the empathy I really
think it was the fact that so I grew up
as a Jehovah's Witness okay and then and
then I went to a very private I went to
a private school so what you're very
isolated from the general population so
I think it's easy to be privileged or
other people struggle you started
sounding like you were maybe operating a
nuclear submarine I don't know if you
just moved into a location that's less
than ideal can you hear me now yes we
can okay what we I think I heard up
until when you said
met black people Oh
so I I basically went to public school
and I just I'd met more people color
more more minority people and just and
gay people I started to meet like if I
am gay as well so I'm sure that had a
lot to do with it interesting
so my question even is I'm a Bernie
Sanders fan and I want to know you know
given that the stock market it's an
indication or somewhat of an indication
of how the wealthy are doing and how
like corporate elitists are doing
doesn't it make sense or is it not it's
reasonable to assume that if Bernie
Sanders gets his way in certain aspects
that the stock market will go down or
that the economy will in fact them down
just as a as a means of correction into
a new economic error of Bernie Sanders
no I don't think that that's a that's a
good assumption I mean listen there are
things that you can argue Donald Trump
has done in terms of deregulation and
lowering business taxes which have then
been used to repurchase stock and drive
up the share prices that have been good
for the market but there's also things
that Donald Trump has done that are not
good for markets instability related to
the trade war other types of
geopolitical instability possible
impeachment I mean you know we there's
this whole long list so you could argue
that some of the Bernie Sanders policies
with regard to taxing corporations or
regulating corporations at a surface
level analysis it might suggest that we
would expect stocks to become depressed
historically stocks do better under
Democrats than Republicans even though
Democrats tend to be slightly more for
regulating business and so I think that
there's no historical case to be made
that a Bernie presidency would be bad
for the markets and I think that in the
same way that you can argue some of his
policies might pull down stock prices a
lot of what Bernie wants to do in terms
of making its demand side stimulus
making sure people are at risk of going
bankrupt because of
a health care bill for example in other
ways that he would free up capital for
people to use in a disposable income way
will be beneficial to the economy into
some of those corporations so I reject
the premise that you're proposing here
with peace and love I reject it of
course I just wanted to ask thank you
all right Joseph very good to hear from
you very interesting story let's take a
quick break if you're holding don't hang
up we will go right back to the phones
just after this